well I've been joined Now by Michaela
Peterson of course Jordan's daughter who
was on peers Morgan sensor recently
Michaela I know you were watching that
last interview that I was doing with
your dad there and he got emotional at
the end of that what did you what do you
make of it when you see your dad like
that and why he was emotional in that
case I think to tell you the truth I
think he's worn out from doing 10,000
things every day even when we tell him
to take rests he doesn't take them so I
think that plays a major role um but
also the way our lives have changed has
been overwhelming so when he says he's
overwhelmed all the time I think that
that's accurate yeah I mean Jordan was
saying to me that it overwhelmed by the
sense of responsibility he feels and the
influence that he has now over so many
people brings with it the burden of that
responsibility and it's something he
feels very acutely do you see that with
your dad on a daily
basis
oh oh definitely if people approach him
on the street he gets emotional quite
frequently um because the conversations
are emotional so people come up and say
this is how hard my life was and maybe
my life is still hard but I'm managing
to take it on in a more positive way and
I'm I credit you for that and he gets
emotional and that's all real and it's
because it's an emotional conversation
so I think that that makes sense yeah I
mean Jordan I that is an extraordinary
responsibility what I'm thinking as I I
see the two of you here I read recently
I think it was some Tik Tock thing I saw
but it was uh an old business guy and he
was saying you know the real definition
of success in life is not money or
material things or anything like that
the real definition of success is if
you're a father and your kids when they
become adults and therefore can make
their own decisions
choose to hang out with you because they
want to hang out with you that that's
the ultimate definition of success what
do you think of that
theory oh yeah that that's that's right
I mean I would say I feel that acutely I
would say my wife feels that even more
acutely like she's so thrilled if her
kids want to hang out with her if they
want to do you know committed things
with her that she can hardly stand it
and I mean this is also one of the great
advantages of having a family people
just don't understand this there isn't
anything more important that you will
have in your life than your kids period
and and it's s such we we lie to young
women so terribly by telling them that
their career will be where will be where
they find the meaning in their life I
mean I have a stellar career but and I'm
pretty damn thrilled about it and I
should be
but it's it takes second place to my
wife and my kids and then to my extended
family
as well and so and if you organize I
think that's true even if your family
isn't working that well and it's
definitely true if it's working well I
mean why wouldn't you want to be around
the people that you love that's sort of
the definition of
Love Michaela I mean I would imagine
you've had sort of a weird life in one
respect where for a long time your dad
wasn't a globally renowned figure right
and then he became one uh what was that
transition like for you as his daughter
to see your dad go from your dad and an
academic and a psychologist and so on
man to suddenly become this sort of you
know odd Superstar of you know with with
an influence over millions of people
what what was that like for
you well completely surreal at the
beginning so I I remember walking down
blor street in Toronto when this first
happened and he was still a university
University professor and seeing a
picture of Dad on the front cover of a
newspaper um and it said something like
Hy Jordan it was something like that
comparing him to Hitler and it was the
newspaper I used to read on the Metro on
the way to school and I was like well
guess I who knows how many lies I've
been reading from that
newspaper um and then for the
next I would say I would say our family
probably only really stabilized in the
last year and a half so it
took what is that six
years to kind of come to grips with what
had happened to my dad and at the very
beginning um he was kind of lost to the
Internet so everybody was wrapped up in
this but at the dinner table and
whenever we had conversations it was
really focused on what was the news
saying was he going to lose his job what
was happening uh online and it was hard
to focus on anything other than that
even if we said okay you know no media
at the dinner table it was still hard to
focus on anything other than that and I
think part of the reason I stepped in to
help you and Mom was to have something I
was also involved in so that I could be
part of the conversation and I think um
my brother Julian probably felt that to
the same degree was okay well I guess
we've moved from kind of having this
normal more normal family relationship
to
whatever whatever it is now yeah you see
it's really interesting I mean they I
love the chemistry between you two um
I've got a younger daughter she's 11
I've got three much older Sons all in
their 20s one 30 now very different
thing very special relationship I think
a father and daughter but you talked
there Michaela about a normal sort of
family world I find it hard Jordan to
believe that the Peterson family has
ever been conventionally
normal
were we normal you want to go
there I feel like it was a lot more
normal than it is now that's for sure
like we still had school you worked you
had a number of jobs so you worked a lot
mom was at home and we had more of a
dinner routine and a schedule so we had
that but I think things were still a
little weird now that I know what other
families look like more when you're
isolated in one weird family you don't
know that it's weird for a while
I think the depths of concern in in our
household and and in my life made our
existance somewhat not run-ofthe-mill
not typical I mean the artwork in the
house I suppose was an example of that I
mean Michaela grew up in a house there
were I don't know 300 paintings I
suppose in our little house I I had
Lenin fall on my head in my bedroom when
I came back from happened to every teen
Lenin yeah wasn't a great
I mean that's the that's the real
question what was it that hit you on the
head it was this I would say 7 Foot by
4ot painting that Dad had put into my
bedroom I don't think I was I don't
think I wanted Lennon in my bedroom
looking at me but he why not he'd put it
in my bedroom and yeah I was sleeping
one night and it fell over I was like
that's it I thought if the schools the
schools were going to do it super
surreptitious ly I would just do it
directly you had a gigantic picture of
Lenin in your bedroom that fell on your
head is that what you're
say yeah it kind of just leaned over it
didn't crush me you were literally
struck down by
communism
yeah Jordan what kind of father do you
think you were when Michaela was was
younger because I'll get ahead a fact
check
it playful playful yeah we had a lot of
fun I mean
the people I grew up with my friends in
junior high and high school and and even
later all we really did was engage in
competitive bouts of humor like all the
status among the people I hung around
with was who could say the most
outrageous and comical thing and I
really like I've always really liked
little kids I really like playing with
little kids and I'm quite good at it as
my father was it's one of his sort of
Stellar traits the ability to he really
likes little kids and he liked me when I
was little kid so that was a good deal
and I really liked being with my kids I
really enjoyed playing with them I
there's very little that I would rather
do than play with little kids who are
well behaved it's ridiculously fun
they're extremely comical they have a
very clown-like nature they're
imaginative and they see the world
through fresh eyes and that's a great
deal and so whenever I had a moment when
I wasn't working I spent it with my kids
and and my wife and we we had a good
time I mean we had our troubles partly
because Michaela was so ill but it was
always play and humor and teasing and
but not mean you know like fun I mean
you both competive fun and both my kids
have vicious senses of humor and so
that's great and I I had the same with
mine I know exactly what you mean
Michaela you've had periods in your life
as a family where your dad has probably
feared he may lose you you feared you
may lose your dad and you both both may
have feared that you would lose your mom
Michaela and Jordan your wife I mean
you've had some extraordinary things to
deal with as a family how have you dealt
with
that have you dealt with that I don't
have PTSD anymore so I think I've dealt
with that uh how did we deal with
that we communicated we communicated a
lot
yeah and pray
at the end when it got really tough so
that's interesting we tried to find our
way through I told Michaela when she was
a little kid I told her at one point
when she got really sick I said we had a
very serious conversation she wasn't a
very old girl I said look kid you're
going to have a very hard life it's
going to be brutal and this is after we
knew she she had the worst case of
arthritis that the Toronto sick kids had
ever hospital had ever seen that's not a
diagnosis you want to hear from a
hospital not a big hospital you're child
has the worst case of this illness we've
ever seen it's like what's her
prognosis multiple early joint
Replacements so that's like painful
degeneration followed by early death oh
yeah that's not so good well so what's
worse than
that well what's worse than that is
adopting the role of victim becoming
resentful and turning against life
because then you get to have multiple
early collapse joints followed by death
then you get to be ultim Ely miserable
and in hell at the same time so I sat
her down and I said look kid you can't
don't ever use your illness as an excuse
like it's going to be difficult for you
to do things difficult for you to get up
in the morning to go to school it's
going to be painful and it's even going
to be hard for you to tell when you can
do something and when you can't when
you're justified in saying look Dad I
just can't get out of bed said don't
fool yourself about your illness because
then you won't be able to distinguish
what you can do from what you can't do
and then you will truly be lost and she
listened you know even I don't think you
were more than about nine or 10 when we
had that conversation she listened I had
a conversation with my son at about the
same time you know and I said look kid
your sister is very sick and we're
screwed and the probability that I'm
going to be able to pay sufficient
attention to you for the next few years
is like zero you're going to have to
like face this and you're going to have
to grow up and take this on yourself and
you cannot be any troubled because we've
got enough trouble anymore it's going to
sink us and so he listened and he was no
trouble I mean how was how was Julian
with you when you were at
home good very good compassionate for
somebody who's fairly disagreeable right
yeah yeah and he stuck around he was at
home I mean he had lots of friends and
he did his teenage things but he came
home and and he helped and he was no
trouble he had things to deal with but
he took care of them himself we have a
clip of of you guys with Judy think just
several years ago uh which to show
people just to show who Jullian
is and so one of the great ways to
figure out what to write about is well
what bugs
you notice that that's that involuntary
rumination that's the manifestation of
underlying complexes from a
psychoanalytic perspective so
something's on your mind poking you
bugging you it's like jimy Cricket in in
Pinocchio that is really
annoying that's I did it I knew that
would bug
you it's a great it's a great clip we
don't see a lot of Julian you know he's
not as high profile as you two um but
you're a very tight family I mean
Michaela the way your dad Tau that it
could be taken as being tough love or it
could be just a reality check of look
you can either spend the next few years
of your life feeling sorry for yourself
or you can crack on with life and make
the best of it which is exactly the
advice I would have given one of my
children in that position but how did
you feel at the time you had given
it well I think I remember that and I
think I was in grade two so um I would
have been seven or eight I was pretty
little so I didn't even like at that
time I didn't even understand what
arthritis was I thought oh great I have
an old person disease that's as much as
I understood and I didn't want to tell
anybody about it because it was an old
person disease um and so I don't even
think I had second thoughts about
anything dad said because I was so young
I just figured okay that's my dad that's
what he says I should do then I'll do it
I don't think I thought anything more
than that but I do think that was
instrumental in getting out of chronic
illness honestly uh yeah cuz you barely
got out of it if you would have
complicated it up with some additional
stupidity some
resentment I think that's probably true
in our family in general I mean we
didn't do things perfectly but we did
our best not to be resentful and
resentment is really a killer I think if
you would have bured yourself with
victimized
resentment you wouldn't have made it
yeah you know what I did rather than
become resentful uh and I don't know if
this was a healthy thing to do but I got
really angry I didn't get angry at
anybody per se I got angry in a um it
wasn't a feeling sory for myself but it
was what am I going to do to get out of
this how dare life do this to me that's
not who I am yep so I was angry for a
long time that's part of you know one of
the things you want to do is you want to
get your anger on your side you want to
put it inside instead of facing you and
stopping you you want to use it as as a
force that drives you forward and you
definitely did that you were a pretty
implacable person you know it's
interesting listening to you both
talking about that because I had a I had
a fascinating conversation a few years
ago with Joe Biden who had just lost his
son bow to brain cancer and obviously
he'd also many years before lost his
wife and baby daughter in a car crash
and his two sons survived and were badly
hurt and so on and everyone knows the
story but I'd written a column a
newspaper column about Bo Biden after he
died because he used to come on my old
show at CNN and I just said look this
guy was an amazing guy he'd been a
States Attorney General he'd been in
Iraq war hero he had a lovely family he
was going right to the top I felt
politically he may even have become
president candidate perhaps and I said
he he'll now be the the best president
America will never know they could have
had and I wrote this column heartfelt I
liked him very much I thought he was
very impressive and Joe Biden called me
he's vice president at the time and I'd
never met him and he he had a 15 20
minute conversation with me and I asked
him I said I've got four children I
don't know how you would ever deal with
losing a child you've had to do this
twice and you lost your first wife how
do you deal with it and he said you know
it's interesting he said as I talk to
you I have in front of me uh a cartoon
strip Hagar the Horrible and it was in
two parts and in one part Hagar was on a
boat that was floundering on the rocks
and he had his Trident and he was
Raising it to the to the the skies in
very stormy conditions and shouting at
the gods why me and in the second part
of the cartoon the gods shout back why
not and he said he got annoyed
originally when he saw that when his dad
his dad found it in a flea market he got
annoyed he thought it was insensitive
and then the more he thought about it
the more he realized what his dad was
saying which is you cannot rationalize
what's happened to you you can't try and
work out why it's happened to you stuff
happens like this to people all the time
uh and in a way it's different but the
way that you talked to Michaela about
her condition it is kind of similar is
that you didn't waste time and energy
trying to rationalize this or explain
why you'd been singled out it was just a
case of it happened we got to deal with
it well I went to Jerusalem with a
friend of mine Jonathan Paso and Paso is
a very brilliant man and we walked the
Via doar Roa which is the root of
Christ's passion with its 12 stations
and each station is a kind of is a is a
is a microcosm of suffering and then of
course the entire journey culminates in
the most unjust suffering imaginable and
that's what the story is the Christian
passion is the story of the most unjust
suffering imaginable and you might say
well what does that have to do with you
and the answer is that's going to happen
to you there's going to be unjust
suffering in your life and you're called
upon to radically embrace that and to
say yes and that's even the case if it's
your children who are called upon to
make the sacrifice that's the story of
Abraham's sacrifice of Isaac God calls
on Abraham to sacrifice Isaac and you
know that seems like a bit much but you
you have to offer your children to the
world you have to offer your children to
be destroyed by the world you have to
say yes to that radically full-heartedly
and the more you do that weirdly
paradoxically the more you do both of
those except that for yourself except
that for your children welcome it the
less
catastrophic the sacrifice has to be
it's so it's so paradoxical well you
think about it you know is if you
protect your children unduly you weaken
them if you let them encounter the world
and and the micro tragedies that go
along with that encounter let's say they
get strong yeah and there's no limit to
that there's no upper end and and so
that's why in the judeo-christian
tradition for example you're enjoyed to
take up your cross and bear it and to
walk up hill nonetheless and the reason
for that is there is no better
alternative of course you have to say
yes to life and that means saying yes to
some
pretty right brutal realities well it's
like uh I mean my favorite movie uh
scene Michaela is from the sixth of the
rocky films and Rocky's son is just in
his 20s and he's he's spoiled he's
entitled he's angry about being the son
of some somebody famous he resents it
and Rocky eventually takes him in the
street and just has it out with him and
he does this speech to his son he says
look life is not a better roses life is
tough it will beat you down if you let
it and it's not about how hard you can
hit hit it's about how hard you can get
hit and get back up and keep moving
forward and it snaps the sun back into
the real world in a way it's it's kind
of what your dad was just talking about
but you've been through that yourself
that process but you also then had to
flip it round when three and a half
years ago your dad was very seriously
ill in a medically induced coma in a
clinic in Russia you were decide
throughout that
process what were you thinking when with
the situation you were dealing with the
Russian
mafia
yeah well what was that what was that
like for you
Michaela oh I cannot even describe how
horrible it was like I thought being
sick myself was bad because it was very
bad I thought getting off of
anti-depressants I went through
anti-depressant withdrawal which was
just horrifying beyond belief I thought
that was bad
watching how sick my dad got was so much
worse than what I went through
that it was hard not to what what did I
think I literally you know what for some
reason for some reason when he got
really sick I I thought I could just
move to LA I was in Toronto and I
thought I could just move to LA we
didn't know what was wrong with him he'd
been to a number of different hospitals
and my mom had been sick and I thought I
could just move to LA and I could do
things by myself and I don't have to
deal with this and then uh I I thought
about it and I had this weird feeling
that whatever was wrong with him which I
thought was anti-depressant withdrawal
which is what had happened to me would
last about 2 years so I sat down and I
decided okay I'm going to do whatever I
can to help this guy and I think it's
going to be Absol ABS solute hell for a
couple of years and I don't know why I
had that feeling but I had this feeling
of this 2-year period and so I decided
rather than running away which had
definitely crossed my mind uh I'd do
everything I possibly could and just put
my life on hold until he got better
which I figured was about two years so
while this was happening particularly
when we were in Russia I was like at
that point I was literally learning
Russian I was like I don't know how long
we're gonna be here Russian is not easy
to learn
um but I was like I you know made a
commitment I'm going to help and see
this through and I believe that he can
get better so I think the way I managed
that was I had a really strong belief
that he's sick but he can get better and
I just have to stick with him till he
gets better and nobody could changeed my
mind from that not even him even though
he tried like I'm not going to make it
like yeah you are you're GNA be fine we
just got to get through this so I think
that's what what helped was a naive
optimism of getting better fascinating
fasc to see the roles reversed there
Jordan but then you both had to deal
with your wife getting very sick with
cancer your mom
Michaela um and you both had to deal
with that what after given what you'd
both been through what was that like for
you as as a unit the pair of you and and
of course Julian in
too well it was remarkable to see her
deal with that really to see Tammy deal
with that because Tammy's very very
tough person and even she got the news
initially that she had a form of cancer
that was 100% fatal in 11 months and
that no treatment there was no evidence
whatsoever that any treatment radiologic
chemotherapeutic or surgical would help
so that we all got that dumped on us in
about 10 minutes and she just took that
in and went on walking and uh in fact I
think she was not really even
overwhelmingly affected Ed by that until
she had to tell Juliet and saw that
reflected in him and that really changed
her because she saw that that made made
more of a difference to him than it did
even to her and so she saw the love she
had granted him because she was an
excellent mother reflected and that
really changed her life it might have
saved her life but it certainly
transformed her permanently and that
took a long time to unfold but Tammy is
a she's one tough cookie and she took
everything on the chin and Tammy
basically was at the edge of death for 3
months every day she just about starved
to death um during the recovery process
from her surgery because of a surgical
complication she lost about almost 30%
of her body weight and she she did
suffer a little bit with post starvation
syndrome as a consequence of that but I
don't think I ever saw
Tammy desperate or resentful during that
whole time no
and she she opened herself up she
accepted help where she could get it she
took every possibility to move forward
that was offered to her
um she opened herself up to
transformation on every front and really
did change and I would say she's now
doing better than she ever has in her
life it's really quite miraculous to see
apart from the fact that she also
recovered and as far as we know she's
the only person who ever survived this
form of cancer incred she said she
credits it I think this is where
mentioning um she it was the weirdest
thing so she got really sick it was
horrible um I wasn't around as much when
she got sick because I had PTSD from my
Hospital experiences and I didn't want
to go into a hospital I went to the
hospitals but like the PTSD was pretty
bad um and she she was stuck in the
hospital and she said I'm gonna get
better this is just such a strange story
she said I'm gonna get better on our
anniversary which uh for Mom and Dad is
mid August and this was
June and she told everybody this and
we're like okay mom like she's on
morphine like not sure what's going on
um and then they flew to the US to do uh
a procedure which didn't work and then
on their anniversary she got
better which was really weird because
nobody was expecting that and she goes
oh it was God and converted to cathol
ISM wow and so that made the entire
period even more surreal because because
what hell it didn't make any sense yeah
it was our 30th Anniversary yeah so
Jordan I would ask you you all the
surgical complication stopped on on our
I mean that is miraculous and it brings
me back to what I asked you when it was
just me and you talking which is whether
you believe in god what happened to your
wife to Tammy and her turning to God in
that
moment did that not give you all the
proof you needed that there is a
God well I was already very religiously
inclined before that I mean I've been
studying religious thinking for 40 years
you know and speaking to my students
about that very diligently during that
whole time and so in some ways I mean
the the anniversary issue that was very
strange yeah and and the Transformations
that have occurred in relationship to
Tammy are quite profound and wonderful
and and hard to believe um was that
additional evidence to me I already had
a lot of evidence you know what we
talked about in another uh I was already
already a firmed believer in hell you
know and I knew there was a route away
from hell and the root away from hell is
a religious pathway so I've been walking
down that pathway a very very long time
so this was just another not just you
know what I mean it's it's a milestone
and a marker but it wasn't for me that
wasn't a qualitative
transformation did you did you dodge the
god question in the previous interview I
wouldn't I wouldn't say so he it was
really it was really interesting and in
fact it's almost like he's almost
rewinding now because I if I'd asked him
right now I I may have got a different
answer because I think Jordan I think
you do believe in God and I think what's
happened to your family
has reinforced that belief but for some
reason you're reticent to just say
modern people modern people don't don't
understand this question they think that
it's a matter of believing in a set of
facts it's not if you believe in God you
allow the spirit of the logos to take
residence within
you now but nobody understands what you
mean if you say that but like think
about it this way Michaela could have
got bitter and resentful well the spirit
of bitter resentment is the spirit
Spirit of Cain because her sacrifices
would have gone unrewarded she would
have been rejected by God and she would
have shaken her fist at the sky and the
spirit of Cain is a luciferian spirit
and it's it's a genocidal spirit and you
can allow that Spirit to take up its
residence within you and that means that
you're a follower of the luciferian
spirit or you can do the opposite you
can allow the the spirit of the logos to
take residence within you and that's
what you're attempting to do if you
adhere a ously to a genuine religious
practice michaa and that's real all
right let me ask let me ask Michaela I
mean you said to me did he Dodge the
question on God why did you say
that just to see what his face would
look like if I said that while he was on
Pierce
Morgan and his body language the arms
went up very quickly I noticed quite
defensive body language uh Mr
psychologist you gave her a chance to be
annoying she immediately took it well
Michaela Michaela go explain why did you
ask him about God you ask you
why well I believe in God yeah and there
and I didn't before or I wasn't sure
before I was never an atheist but you
know when people say Do you believe in
God I'd say I don't know I don't really
get it I'd like to I always wanted to
and so when Mom converted to Catholicism
and I saw you know a whole bunch of
really weird things that I couldn't
logic out happened um let alone dad
becoming famous and then us all getting
so sick and an unbelievable amount of
suffering then mom's miraculous recovery
that she knew ahead ahead of time by two
months the date of that nobody could
explain um yeah well you you learned at
least that you had no idea how the world
worked oh absolutely none that's what I
learned is I don't understand what's
going on at all um but I saw the
transformation that took place in mom
and I saw how much more compassionate
she became because she's a very
disagreeable woman and I wouldn't say
compassion is one of her strong suits
and she became more compassionate
somewhat
dramatically and she's trying to love
everybody in the world now it's very
annoying yeah it's nice uh and and so
that was enough for oh that wasn't quite
enough for me actually it was about a
year later and dad was so sick and
uh and I didn't know I had exhausted
everything I knew how to do to help I
couldn't think of any other way I could
help and I remember praying at that
point because I literally couldn't think
of anything else to do I was just just
like God help us help me um and I think
it was around that period where
something switched and then my life got
easier and I don't know if that's
because I let go of some control that I
don't actually have but my life switched
directions and I felt calmer in a way
that I couldn't uh describe or come to
any I I couldn't figure out why and I
figured that was God so that was enough
for me to say reality isn't exactly how
we see it there's more going on out
there and and Michaela if I asked you if
I asked you Michaela do you think your
dad believes in God what would you
say get it
right yeah I think so yeah I do too he
definitely he definitely I I think so he
definitely lives in a way where he knows
that if he acts as if he believes in God
then he avoids hell so I don't know what
the difference between that and belief
is why would you do that if you didn't
believe
right seems reasonable to me right
J sometimes it's always good to bring
out the daughter uh because you you'll
get the truth out of the dad you know
you can you can put the old arms up to
me Jordan down there from America but
you can't to your daughter sitting
sitting right next to you she she knows
you better than you probably know
yourself very sneaky plan on your
part M I want to play you a tape this is
from a a podcast in which you talked
about uh getting
divorced it was very very difficult to
get divorced considering what my dad
talks about it made me stay in a
relationship longer than I should have I
don't agree with the more
conservative story of divorce that
people are being told I think being in a
relationship that's not good for you I
think you should get out of that
relationship interesting that uh let me
ask you Jordan when you heard her say
that did you feel any responsibility
that she may have stayed in a very
unhappy marriage for too long because
she didn't want to upset you because of
your
views no no I wouldn't say so I I'm able
to let my
children handle the complexity of Their
Own Private Lives knowing at least I
think as I do that there isn't that's a
place where only fools would would go
and I had faith that she would sort
things out you know and so I I'm per I
was willing to give her her space I mean
I believe in committed marriage
and so
um at that level of
generality obviously I have objections
to the breakup of a marriage but you
know I have faith in my daughter and so
I believe
she'll I believe she's oriented to find
her way and finding your way is a
complex process and I'm willing to stand
back and watch her and to provide
whatever help I can along the way but
also not to interfere too much and I do
think she has in the past found her way
through some very very difficult even
impossible situations and she's taken on
a very
large array of complex responsibilities
in The Last 5
Years even beyond what people thought
she was capable of handling and has done
that in a stellar Manner and so I have
no doubt that she like my son and my
wife are able and willing to find their
own way and so and that is what's
happening so hooray for that Michaela
thanks michaa
you're uh are you you're remarried now
right yes and your name the name of your
of your second
husband uh Jordan
fer now a conspiracy theorist
psychologist funny I know he does you
ended up marrying a man named Jordan
should I be reading anything into this
if I was a clinical psychologist oh I
have no idea like like I said before I
don't know how the world works I don't
think so my secretary is named Jordan
too this is very weird now everyone in
your world is this is like being in
barie
World
[Laughter]
yep true with Michaela because her
husband looks like
Ken is that true
Michaela yes like 100% true yeah I want
to play you both a clip you your dad's
had a lot of feuds with people uh some
he starts some he doesn't some he gets
just gets picked up for the sake of it
there's a lot of feminists who he winds
up very successfully I would say because
they're very easy to wind up um one of
them is Caitlyn Moran who's currently in
America and she's using your dad a lot
uh ranting away about him here's one
clip of her talking about your
dad he shared a piece to his 10 minutes
ion followers in which I think I do a
pretty good demolishment job of his
entire career and erra the advice that
he gives is either the kind of stuff
your mom would say for free like make
your bed pet a cat in the street or mad
stuff about lobsters I didn't even go to
school at our University and I was
halfway through his book going I'm
fairly sure I can demolish a great deal
of the logic in this book this guy is
not the smartest guy in the world he's
just a man in a waste coat who sounds to
be honest a bit like Kermit from The
Muppet Show Kermit from The Muppet Show
your
thoughts well that's true I do sound a
lot like Kermit from The Muppet Show so
that was the one thing she said that
that was accurate that's not even her
joke though that's not clever if you
steal it from somebody else no it's an
old joke but it was a good one when it
first came out mm so what do you think
of her it sounds like she'd be fun at a
party or your mother yeah or as your
mother as your mother yeah yeah
yeaha m do you think people like Caitlyn
Moran do they just basically
misunderstand what your dad really is
about I don't even think they're capable
of understanding what he's about there's
too much arrogance there you can't be
that arrogant and assume you know
everything and then read something and
learn or read anything and
learn right that's why you don't cast
pearls before swine
deer you know my my sons as I think I've
told you before are all big fans of
yours and they they just said to me they
got one question which what advice do
you give uh for children who are the
children of controversial public
figures well you know Michaela has leapt
out and and taken the opportunities that
came along with that in the public way
my son Julian is a more private person
and he's chosen to erect barriers around
his family and not to face the public as
much although he has played his music at
my lectures and and he works with me I
think you know each person has to find
their own way there are great advantages
to having a tremendous amount of
attention devoted to you and having
people offer opportunities but each
person depending on their own
temperamental proclivities has to figure
out how to manage that themselves and
it's complex but it can work I mean
Julian Tammy Michaela have all reacted
to that in their own way it took tamy a
good while like the rest of us to figure
out what her place was so to speak but
she's really managed that and Tammy is
out in public much more than I would
have thought she would have been um you
know if I would have guessed if I would
have been able to see into the future 10
years ago she's become quite an
accomplished public speaker for example
and she certainly didn't think that was
in her in her cards in the cards or in
the Stars but um things come at you and
you surf the wave and and you're happy
for the opportunity and Julian and
Michaela and Tammy have all adapted in
their various ways and I think at the
moment that's working like a charm
Michaela if I if I asked you Michaela
obviously the family's gone through this
extraordinary six seven years or more
now involving some extraordinary
challenges for you or personally which
would have happened anyway or perhaps
not actually in your dad's case but
certainly for you and your mom um but
you've come out and you you got
fabulously wealthier as a family I guess
than before this started fabulously more
famous than before it started but if I
had the power to transport you back to
anonymity without the fame without the
extra money and all the rest of it would
you would you take that deal or would
you be actually quite happy where you've
all washed up
now
oh I there's no way I would take that
deal uh even with everything we went
through I was talking to my husband the
other day about why I'm interested in
making money versus why he is and he
said he always liked expensive things
basically and I said I didn't I'm like
decked out right now but I also didn't
mind buying things from thrift shops and
decorating my room that way I didn't
want to feel vulnerable anymore from not
having enough money and so my yearn to
be successful was always so that I would
be less vulnerable so that when I had a
problem I had money to help me solve it
and that was my motivation uh and so I
wouldn't want to go back to be before
because I feel more secure and less
vulnerable now that was also my
motivation to get a social media
following was because there was negative
articles coming out about Dad and then
there were negative articles coming out
about me and I didn't have a platform to
fight back and I thought if if I have a
platform and a media article comes out
then I can tell people my side of the
story and I'm not as vulnerable one
thing one thing that money has
definitely bought you Jordan is a better
fashion sense I mean the the the radical
change in you in the smart suits the the
crop the your hairstyle everything you
have really been dragged Kicking and
Screaming into into the pinup
World well you know when I went out on
tour the first time I thought I'm going
to go speak to you know a third of a
million people and I thought well okay
you should probably be happy about that
and you should probably try to do it
right and Stage Show fundamentally it's
in the theater you probably deck
yourself out so I went and got a couple
of very good suits and and that had all
sorts of strange consequences including
over time that most of the people many
of the people who came to my shows
started showing up in three-piece suits
and relative ly formal attire which is a
lovely thing to see and and that that
saying yes to that and not and not being
condesending towards it you know I was
never overwhelmingly interested in
fashion but I didn't assume that I was
morally Superior because of my ignorance
and disinterest and and then because I
said yes to that a whole Avenue opened
up a whole Avenue opened up there in
a surreal and comical away and now I'm
having a really good time with it and
now you've reached it's very fun it's
yeah obviously great fun and you look by
the way you look sharp so
congratulations um thank you sir what
you're both doing now is this Academy
tell me about the Peterson Academy what
what is the Michaela for you what is the
purpose of
this uh the purpose is
to allow people a proper 2023 style
education um I I think that what you
learned what you learn in universities
generally speaking is taught through an
ideological filter it's overpriced and I
don't think it actually improves you as
a person and I think generally speaking
you can say that for almost every
University and we have the ability now
to learn online from genius people so we
figured why not produce
courses that are extremely well edited
allow the professors to teach the way
they would want to teach without the
guidelines put in place on them by the
universities and then give it a give
access to everybody and then anybody
who's actually interested in learning
and retaining that information to better
themselves has a place to go a social
media platform where they can meet other
people uh which I think will be very
interesting we don't know how that's
going to go um but I'm hoping it'll give
people the opportunity to learn and meet
other people who are like-minded yeah we
have great professors and and one of the
advantages to being in the position that
I'm in at the moment and this is partly
a consequence of my podcast is that I
can find great speakers from all around
the world because I'm also touring
around the world and every time I find
someone I think wow you're so
interesting I can hardly stand it I
think how would you like to come down to
Miami and record a lecture and virtually
everyone says yes and then they come
down to Miami and we put them in the
studio and we treat them very very
nicely and we do that because we're
actually happy that they're there and we
tell them you can teach whatever you
want the way you would dream to teach if
you if you could have what you wanted
and so then people come down there and
do that and they're pretty happy about
that and then they're often willing to
do another course well why wouldn't they
be so I just want to ask you both uh
finally uh this really is it's clear to
me from interviewing you both together
you have an extraordinary Bond um you
clearly love each other very much you're
a very tight family it's been through a
hell of lot of challenges
but if I was to ask you Jordan and then
I'm going to ask you Michaela the other
side ask you Jordan what is it that you
love about Michaela what would you
say she's pretty damn
funny she's tough man don't mess with
her she'll bite you and you'll remember
it so she's a formidable person like my
wife like my son they're fun to be
around don't mess with them that's a
pretty good
combination it is Michaela what would
you say about your dad why do you love
your
dad he's incredibly compassionate and
open so there's opportunity everywhere
in a positive way and he cares deeply
about everything that that's going on um
in people's
lives definitely you've definitely have
more compassion for the average person
than I do I I kind of
think come on there you're a hard ass
maybe maybe try a little harder but
that's that's not what you think yeah uh
so I would say what I love about him is
his openness uh which has led our family
I mean to where it is now I think is him
saying yes to opportunity and being open
and compassionate yeah what a great way
to end uh thank you both so much for all
the time you've given me uh I think
you're a great family I think you're an
important family I think in a world
where people are scared to express their
opinions they don't know what to think I
think both of you in different ways but
also and you have commonality too but in
different ways you you're really having
a huge influence over millions and
millions of people around the world and
it's an influence I know you take very
seriously and it moves you both and I
think that's uh an extraordinary thing
and I wish you all the best in
continuing with that but thank you both
very much indeed for joining Piers
Morgan on
Sensi thank you very much Pier thank
you